we're told Divya is seated on a ferris
wheel at time T equals zero the graph
below shows her height H in meters T
seconds after the ride starts so at time
equals zero she is looks like about two
what is this this would be one and a
half so it looks like she's about to two
meters off the ground and then as time
increases she gets as high as it looks
like this is close to 30 maybe 34 meters
and then she comes back down back to
looks like two meters and up two to be
34 meters again so let's read the
question so the question asks us
approximately how long does it take
Divya to complete one revolution on the
ferris wheel
alright so this is interesting so this
is when she's at the bottom of the
ferris wheel so then she gets to the top
of the ferris wheel
and then she keeps rotating until she
gets back to the bottom of the ferris
wheel again so it took her six T and T
is in terms of seconds so it took her 60
seconds to go from the bottom to the
bottom again another 60 seconds she
would have completed another revolution
and so let me fill that in it is going
to take her 60 seconds 60 seconds and we
of course can check our answer if we
like let's do another one of these so
here we have a doctor observes the
electrical activity of Finn's heart over
a period of time the electrical activity
of Finn's heart's heart is cyclical as
we hope it would be and it Peaks every
0.9 seconds which of the following
graphs could model a situation if T
stands for time in seconds and E stands
for the electrical activity of Finn's
heart in volts well over here looks like
we peaked at zero seconds and then here
we're picking a little bit more than one
this looks like maybe at one point one
now maybe at two point two and three
point three this looks like it's
speaking a little bit more than every
one second so like maybe every 1.1
seconds not every zero point nine
seconds so I'd rule out a this one is
peaking
it looks like the interval between Peaks
is less than a second but looks like a
good business in a second so it looks
like maybe every three quarters
a second or maybe every four-fifths of a
second not quite nine-tenths nine-tenths
this first peak would be a little bit
closer to one but this one is close
choice C is looking good
the first we're at zero then the first
peak this looks pretty close to one was
less than one it looks like a tenth less
than one so I like choice C that choice
D it looks like we're peaking every half
second so it's definitely not bad so
this looks like a peak of every 0.9
seconds this is the best representation
that I this is the best representation
that I can think of and you can you can
actually verify that you have a peak
every every 0.9 seconds you're gonna
have four peaks in 3.6 seconds so one
two three four this is it this looks
like it's at three point six over here
you have one two three four you've had
four peaks in less than three seconds so
this definitely one this one definitely
isn't 0.9 so instead of just even
forcing yourself to eyeball just between
the this peak and that peak you can say
well if for every point nine seconds how
long would three peaks take or four
peaks and then you can actually a little
bit more precise as you try to eyeball
it so we can check our answer and verify
that we got it right